it's banned in Europe this is the kind
of thing that isn't allowed in Europe
but makes it to America that's the kind
of thing today we're gonna be trying the
new Starbucks crystal ball Frappuccino
maybe it'll be shiny yeah
or shimmery maybe have some vanilla in
there I'm thinking more like blueberry
chocolate I'm also wondering if there's
maybe gonna be a really cool color
gradient it's definitely gonna be cute
definitely it's gonna be Instagram what
is this what it's green at the bottom it
is it is it me I want to take a picture
of it before I mix it together do you
want this one in it oh yeah let's do
both good they're different
portrait mode sugar crystals Wow you're
like crystals this matches my outfit
oh there's the color gradient yeah take
selfies is that okay mess up the video
oh we're cute come closer
okay thick here's that some yellow in
there or do we sit from the top yeah I'm
gonna go from the bottom is it taste
fruity oh wow
pure sugar just like I thought the more
I drink it like I feel like it's making
me magical there's like a fruity it's
like fruity milk
I wonder if I mix it a little bit if it
changes yeah it's a little strong at the
bottom I feel like a child eating Pixy
sticks there's like a peaches and cream
flavor to the whole thing I actually
really like this I feel like this is
less of a magic crystal ball and more of
like a tropical seahorse fruta Chino
it's a sassy sassy sugar fest in my
mouth and I'm not
I probably would and sis Tori this
because it's very weird looking overall
I think the drink is good when I get it
again it has a quality about it it just
makes you want to go back for more and
only buy like frappuccinos when I'm sad
so it's fine but I would buy this if I
needed it I do enjoy things that just
sort of like spice up the day yeah this
is a fun Thursday because this bit of
magic we're just two girls hanging out
drinking fraps being magical and my
lipstick stayed on oh yeah I know girl